labour thinks it has the government on
the run over allegations of slaves and
corruption at westminster
it was the leader of the house jacob
rees-mogg who had to stand up and
announce a humiliating u-turn over
attempts to overturn owen patterson's
suspension his opposite number was
withering in her criticism saying tory
mps had quote voted to allow corruption
to take place unimpeded at the heart of
british politics
shadow leader of the house tingham
debonair joins me now good morning miss
debonair
good morning i i guess you've just been
um listening to to george eustis um
are you convinced that it was just a
thing that happened and um
the government just had
listened and
did the right thing
i hardly know where to start with that
the leader of the house my opposite
number literally lays the business if
he'd wanted to reform the appeals to any
sort of part the standards process at
any time over the last however many
years he could have put that before
parliament and he didn't he was the one
that put the amendment to it supported
the amendment to the motion on wednesday
which should have been about reinforcing
the standards committees
effectively an appeals process that is
what the standards committee does it
assesses the evidence that the standards
commissioners put before them and allows
witnesses it takes statements it takes
statements in this case for mom and
paterson himself and they came to the
conclusion that we should support the
standards commissioner's findings now it
was jacob rees-mogg himself who decided
to veer away from that motion and
support the backbench amendment from the
um dispatch box i said to him at that
time that this was a conflation of two
things so it was felt a bit rich that he
the next morning said it's unfortunate
that it's been conflated it was
literally the government that complained
the two this is tori sleeves pure and
simple i said so at the time and i'm
afraid to say that as the whole thing
has unraveled throughout the week it's
more and more what it looks like tori
sleeves and it's on the prime minister
are you amongst the group of people who
think that uh the house should be now
deprived of the services of jacob
rees-mogg as leader of the house that he
should resign
well that's for others to say but i have
to say it's been an extraordinary week
for jacob given that he was trying to
make out that he had no power whatsoever
over when to bring motions in the house
when he could have done it any time
given that he didn't seem to have taken
notice of what i said to him very
clearly as did others uh in the debate
that this was completing two issues and
then he then then gets up the next
morning and says it's unfortunate given
that he still left us in a state of
chaos the motion the amended motion
still stands on monday he really does
need to stand up and move a motion to
rescind
that motion uh which has to happen in my
view before uh before tuesday is over
that's got to happen the government
themselves and i think jacob should be
going to say this to the prime minister
needs to make clear that owen patterson
will not be recommended for a peerage
and we need to be supporting the
standards committee's report now the
standards committee their report is
still there for us to vote for i'd like
jacob to do the right thing bring a
proper motion so that we can vote
before we get on to all of that just
before we get on to all that i i've i've
put it to you really nicely but let me
be just blunt are you saying that this
terrible chap jacob rees-mogg's done all
these things that you've just been
talking about
uh should resign or not well i think now
when are you ever going to do that
it's an extraordinary thing for the
leader of the house to have so little
control over the leader of the house if
i was him i'd be considering my position
that's what i think he should do today
so so he should go
uh i think his position is untenable yes
great thank you for that now look um
all of that said
does labor think that there is any case
at all for looking at the way this is
done
that do you think there was no merit in
in patterson's claim about the way that
the process went
well i think it was extraordinary for
anybody to say there is no appeals
process in the system at the moment
because of course there is as i've
explained the standards committee
reviews the evidence they take further
evidence if necessary they can ask the
standards commissioner to go back and
look again and in this case they've
considered the web evidence overwhelming
so there already is an effect in the
appeals process but we can always
strengthen the process of course since
1695 for over 300 years all we've ever
done as parliament has strengthened that
process and what the prime minister and
jacob rees-mogg and his chief whip what
they tried to do last week was weaken it
the stannis committee is even now
looking at they are already reviewed the
code of conduct for mps as is quite
right and proper as they do every
parliament that's in process we should
let that happen chris bryant my
colleague who's chair of the spanish
committee which has got lay people on it
and it's got his cross-party
representation they should be allowed to
do their job we should support them in
doing their job when they come back with
their report we should look at it very
carefully
um
if by the way uh
mr patterson he's a former cabinet
minister and all that were recommended
for peerage um what would labour do
about it
well we obviously would not be
recommending anyone like uh mr patterson
for appearance and i hope that the prime
minister c sense and rules that out we
have called it out and said he should
not be recommended for a peerage i would
be calling and my colleagues will be
calling for that to be ruled out by the
government and that should happen at the
earliest possible opportunity it's not
too late for the prime minister to do
that today he could rule it out now i
mean i i saw mr useless complaining
about press coverage who seemed to be if
he wants the bad press coverage to stop
they could do this now they could rule
out mr patterson being recommended for a
peerage they could rule out they could
get rid of the motion that they passed
last week as amended they could make
sure that's coming for the house this
week there's any number of things that
they could do which we would do they all
also could do a pierced armor it would
do which is establish an anti-sleaze
anti-corruption unit with real teeth and
real powers which is what labour would
do in government and we would also be
respecting as we do now the independence
of the standards commissioner and the
independence cross party with lay
members of the committee
okay um degradation of politics isn't
entirely the property of conservatives
um and money isn't the only thing that
brings mps into disrepute um former
labour mp claudia webb's been given an
18-month uh sentence for harassment is
this the kind of conduct that
leads people to say
actually they're all as bad as each
other
well in contrast to the tory party as
soon as claudia was charged we suspended
her from the labour party as soon as she
was convicted her we expelled her we
have called on her to resign and if she
doesn't we will support a recall
petition to make sure that her
constituents get to vote for someone
else
all right let's uh return to uh politics
in general
where does this leave the government in
your opinion uh with its reputation and
so on
i feel it leaves the government with its
reputation in tatters but particularly
the tory prime minister boris johnson he
does seem to have a thought form here
there's a pattern of behavior if we go
back to the illegal corrugation of
parliament for instance that was an
astonishing thing for a law any lawmaker
to support let alone the prime minister
to lead on we are law makers we should
not be law breakers we should be
upholding a system of standards and i'm
afraid to say i think the public knows
how to judge i think the public can see
that this week tory mps
led by the tory prime minister tried to
protect someone who'd been found guilty
of doing things that
mp should never do which is take a very
large amount of money for a very large
amount of access i think their
reputation frankly is in tatters and i
hope that boris johnson also considers
his position this weekend and takes the
steps he needs to to repair the
reputation he's damaged the reputation
of politics which is all right
okay so what we've got is um a
government reputation in tatters prime
minister who by what you're saying seems
to be ready should be ready for
resignation a house of commons leader
who should be ready for resignation uh
sleaze on the back benches rising prices
um
rising taxes falling living standards
how is it conceivable that her majesty's
opposition is still behind in the polls
well i think we've we've started to turn
that corner i mean let's not forget we
some of the worst um defeat into oh come
on
you've had all this stuff you and i have
discussed this before
you and i've discussed this before
you're making no progress at all
well i don't think that's fair i think
kia starmer in particular is showing the
public that there really is an
alternative to a man such as boris
johnson who thinks he's above the law
and kia starmer who literally enforced
the law i think people can really see
that contrast they're starting to get to
know him now after a year which was very
difficult for the opposition to get
airtime i think we're now turning that
corner we came out of our conference
really strong with bold policies
particularly on things like climate
change with our 28 billion pounds per
year investment pledge i think that we
are showing that the country that there
is an alternative we've got a way to go
before a general election
and i'm really i'm really sure that he
was showing respect
you said that to me three months ago
when we also when we last spoke uh
nothing has changed
no i don't i don't think that's fair i
think that the public's certainly
starting to see kierstarma as the prime
minister that i know he would be which
is someone who can be relied on as
opposed to boris johnson who can't boris
johnson's polls this morning are
actually down the drain i think no one
can deny that i think we are starting to
see that the public's getting to nokia
and they're realizing that he's the
valid choice for the next prime minister
i know he's going to be a fantastic
prime minister
thank you
thank you very much indeed thank you